for all the moms out there dr fauci
has a special present for your special
day if you are good little girls and you
do every single thing that he says
maybe just maybe you can celebrate
mother's day
next year give everyone a sense of what
the country is going to look like next
mother's day
well george i hope that next mother's
day we're going to see a dramatic
difference than what we're seeing right
now i believe that we will be
about as close to back to normal as we
can and there's
there's some conditions to that george
we've got to make sure that we get the
overwhelming
proportion of the population vaccinated
when that happens
the virus doesn't really have any place
to go there aren't a lot of vulnerable
people
around and where there are not a lot of
vulnerable people around you're not
going to see a surge
you're not going to see the kinds of
numbers we see now
so next mother's day something what 14
months after 15 days to slow the spread
will be not normal we'll be close to
as close to normal as possible
if you all get this shot but if you
don't you're lucking down for another
two years you
sheep happy mother's day i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my only real pang
of i would say almost despair in
politics
is that if i were ever to run for some
office if i were ever to
find myself in some position of
political influence
probably dr fauci will already be out of
his job
because i would love nothing more if i
found myself in a position of political
power i would love nothing more
than to fire dr fauci banish him to
saint helena
and never more hear from him again
frankly though
even if let's say that i run for
something i win something in i don't
know
20 years 30 years on second thought dr
fauci probably still will be in his job
i don't know when that bargain with the
devil runs up i know he's been in office
since what
the truman administration or something
like that so a fair chance i suppose
that he is there speaking of politicians
my favorite comment on friday comes from
extreme taco cannon
who says caitlyn jenner can't win
california needs [ __ ] at a time like
this
and this is a very good point john cox
is a good is a good gubernatorial
candidate put up a you know put up a
fight
in 2018 and and this year i think is
really making a strong play so yes
perhaps california does need [ __ ] at a
time like this
at these very difficult times when
everything is so fraught one way to
give us a little bit of peace of mind
having some physical
gold if you want to invest in physical
gold go check out acre
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30
a month you pay each month and once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars they discreetly ship acre gold
to your house just recently aker
introduced a new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar acre will let you invest without
coming out of pocket all at once so that
you don't you know you don't have to
look around your couch cushion and say
do i have enough for a gold bar yet well
probably you won't but it's a great way
to get started
investing by the way right now you know
there's a nationwide ammo shortage
acre is making a solid gold 24 carat
nine millimeter bullet
that you can buy right now probably not
best to fire out of your gun that would
be a very expensive day at the range
but i suppose good if you want to kill a
werewolf michael werewolves or silver no
actually maybe maybe you've never killed
a werewolf okay
otherwise i would just keep it on your
mantel it's a very cool looking piece
visit getacregold.com michael right now
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acre's giving away a gold bar to qualify
tweet or post why you should get it and
mention at get underscore acre
that is getacre gold.com michael and
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show
everywhere motherhood is being
devalued not just in
in the medical community which is now
trying to erase women entirely
but even in the popular culture put
aside for a second
the transgender issue that says that men
and women are exactly the same and men
are the
the best women around are just men
even in the popular culture motherhood
itself is so devalued there was a clip
from somebody named tiffany haddish the
name vaguely rings a bell though i have
no idea what this person does
tiffany haddish was being interviewed on
some show
and was asked about mother's day and she
said you know i'm i might be a mother i
might have some kids running around i
don't know
here comes something everybody don't
know i'm a tech when i was 21 i was
really hard up with money and i gave up
a bunch of eggs so who knows i might got
some kids out here in the street
there might be some tiffany houses i
doubt though cause i never got the bonus
so man somewhere though and cry out
something
isn't that funny maybe i've got some
kids running around
because i decided that for some pieces
of silver
i would consign my children to never
knowing their mother
this is not adoption by the way it's not
as though i found myself in a
tricky situation and i felt that i
couldn't raise the child but i didn't
want to kill the child so i gave it up
for adoption that's a wonderful selfless
act
this is i wanted some bucks so that i
could entertain myself
so i sold my eggs so that children might
be created
who will never have the opportunity to
know their mother hahaha isn't that
funny
or or maybe they're just in a freezer
somewhere
maybe they have been fertilized but you
know because of all these
other kooky ways that people have
children now
they they have these fertilized embryos
and we just turn them into souls on ice
isn't that funny oh you're so funny
tiffany haddish what a what a great
culture we're living in
oh my goodness gracious what this does
forget about what it does for the kids
that's cruel and selfish enough already
but what it says then is that motherhood
is just
you're just a womb or you're just some
eggs
consider what's happening right now
there's a process that is very popular
among wealthy people where if wealthy
people either can't conceive on their
own
or if there are biological reasons why
they can't in our culture
they will purchase the eggs from one
woman
and then rent out another woman's womb
and then create a designer baby for
their own pleasure and gratification
pretty backwards isn't it isn't the idea
that you love someone else
and so in this act of love you create
another person and this person
is an actual physical representation of
your love that's a selfless
act but to today what we're doing is
exactly the opposite of that
and i guess the worst part of it i mean
you know what's actually
going on is pretty bad but what's even
more shocking to me
is how people don't see it for what it
is how people are just giggling about it
oh teehee he
yeah i sold my children for money that's
what this woman's saying
yeah and they're not gonna know their
their mother you know but ah
what i got some money so isn't that
great ha
meanwhile in pbs pbs newshour
has a peace out on mother's day or i
suppose a couple days before mother's
day but it's obviously for mother's day
uh to really to celebrate women by
saying quote
it's time to recognize the damage of
childbirth
doctors and mothers say now when you
think about
childbirth you're i'm sure you were
celebrating your mother this weekend
when you're thinking about childbirth do
you think of damage
and harm and injury or do you think of
giving life the exact opposite of injury
and harm
probably it would be the latter and
here's how i can prove it there
there is logical flaw in in this
argument from pbs
it's time to recognize the damage of
childbirth doctors and mothers say
first paragraph generations of women
have quietly endured the messy business
of giving birth
even after reading stacks of pregnancy
books faithfully following their health
care provider's advice
and successfully delivering a healthy
baby women often
enter motherhood with what suddenly
feels like a broken body
i didn't even need to read the whole
paragraph do you see the logical flaws
in the first sentence
generations of women have endured the
messy business of childbirth i'm not
saying that childbirth isn't messy
but i'm saying if your argument here is
that childbirth
damages that it harms that it causes
injury
you can't begin your argument with
generations of women it's just like
how ronald reagan made the observation
that everyone who is in favor of
abortion has already been born
or you'll notice there are people
usually on the left who
are worried about the population bomb
they always talk about overpopulation
and notice their solution is never to
take themselves out of the population
the solution is always to take other
people out of the population
because you can't make that argument say
childbirth is bad
childbirth is terrible say generations
of women
yes or is there pain associated with
childbirth yes there is there is pain
and sacrifice involved in anything
that is giving of yourself that is
productive in this world
but nobody wants to give of themselves
anymore because we all want to get
something for nothing
about me me me me and me me
me this is part of a cultural revolution
think about
in the past i'm not saying that long ago
i'm saying like 30 40 years ago
if you said i want to just pursue my own
pleasure and do whatever is good for me
and not care about anybody else
that would be considered bad that would
be considered vicious that would be
considered dishonorable
today this is considered a virtue this
is a good thing right we've made pride
the ultimate virtue for goodness sakes
meanwhile in the past 40 years ago or so
if you said
things like honor
virtue selflessness
sanctification these sorts of words they
would have meant something they would
have been something that we all aspire
to today
those words if you say them to most
people on the street they will look at
you like you've got three heads they
don't make a lot of sense
it is part of a cultural revolution to
upend
the traditional basis of our culture the
traditional practices of our culture
just up in our neighbor to the north
america's hat over
the past week a that pastor that polish
pastor up there
whose name is artur pavlovsky leave it
to the polls to always be defending
freedom
and western christendom
pavlovsky was arrested in the middle of
a street
by a swat team in canada for inciting
people
to go to church see him down look
it looks like a fairly busy road
there are the cops hands behind his head
he's on his knees
she's wearing a suit to go preach to his
congregation
hello friends this is pastor art
polowski if you're watching this video
that means
they have successfully arrested me and i
am
in jail if you would like to support me
if you like to support rebel news and
the legal team that is trying their best
to get me out of this trouble
please go to safearthur.com
please donate please help help me help
my family help my
wife and my children to get me out of
this
horrible illegal situation
please go to safearthur.com and get me
out of this
so this is the pastor we played him on
the show month or so ago whenever
whenever he had his first stand against
these people
and he wouldn't let the the public
health police come into his
congregation and he called them gestapo
and he called them
uh nazis and communists and you know the
polls know a thing or two about what
about this topic
this is canada it's not the united
states yet
but it's going to create a very strange
situation here because if the cops ever
start doing that in america god forbid
is the right gonna back the blue i'm not
gonna back the blue if the blue
is is arresting pastors i don't think
they would do that in america
or i don't think they would want to do
that in america but could it come down
to that
what those cops are they are behaving
like gestapo that's how else do you
describe it
to arrest someone for for holding a
church service
they don't arrest other people for
holding other gatherings
this is specific the churches close and
the marijuana dispensaries remain open
in california during the lockdown
this is not about a uniform standard
it's about creating a new
ranking of priorities and an upending
of the culture and if we don't stand up
against it now
it's it's not like that's some video out
of you know 19
1930s uh europe or
russia that's happening right now right
up to the north just
last week so you've got the police force
in canada
arresting a pastor for holding a church
service because he is
violating the state established church
of
secular progressivism he's violating the
true priests of canada
who are the public health experts and
we've got the same thing here folks it's
not quite as far down the line as it is
in canada
but we've got the same sort of thing
here the same kind of rules on the books
the same kind of punishments albeit to a
lesser degree
meanwhile in the digital realm the
liberal establishment is quashing any
and all dissent
you saw this just last week when
president trump lost his twitter account
again this i felt was really when big
tech crossed the rubicon
in january 7th january 8th when the big
tech companies de-platformed the duly
elected sitting president of the united
states
that's what they did and
you think well if the oligarch nerd
weirdo hipster rasputin types in silicon
valley
can censor the sitting president of the
united states
they control 90 of the flow of
information they control our public
square
so if they censor him that's it that's
that is a political
action it's not just a private company
or a cultural action that's a political
action
well what won't they do certainly
they're going to censor all of us
so president trump tried to work his way
around this by setting up a blog on his
website
and then creating little share buttons
so you can share it to the various
social media companies
and then creating a twitter account for
the blog
but they took that down right away too
they're not going to let him come back
we talked about this last week when
facebook
outsourced its decision to the oversight
board so facebook
censors president trump facebook has a
quasi-independent oversight board
it's independent mostly of corporate
interference but politically it's very
far left wing
so the oversight board is then supposed
to rule on whether or not you can keep
trump banned
first of all if you ban him for the last
part of his presidency then who really
cares if you let him back on two years
later
but even so the oversight board decided
to punt that question back to corporate
because no one really wants to take
responsibility for censoring trump
they all want to censor trump but no one
wants to take responsibility for it
because it is such an
obvious and outrageous political power
grab and what this reminds us and it
should especially remind right-wingers
this
is we can't just privatize everything
you can't just privatize your politics
the reason that facebook even has to
make these content decisions about
censorship
and what's beyond the pale and we have
to all acknowledge look there are some
things that you're just not allowed to
say this has been true from the
beginning of the country this has always
been true in the united states
and it's been true in every country in
the history of the world
you can't engage in things like fraud
you can't engage in things like
sedition to greater or lesser degrees
you can't engage in things like direct
threats you can't you for a long time in
this country you couldn't engage in
obscenity
so there are always things that are off
limits if the
if the politics is not going to make
that decision
then the private companies semi-private
companies are facebook is going to do it
so the response to this
for conservatives is we need to set
these sorts of standards
through our politics or else the left is
going to set the standards for us
instead of hauling off perverts and
communists
with our police like we did in the 1950s
you know busting up
i don't know porn theaters in new york
or busting up communist rings in
washington dc
now what we're seeing is police busting
up churches
it's going to happen we are going to
have standards so what standards are
they going to be
who's going to set it
what are we conserving and how are we
going to do it rahm emanuel
a former mayor former mayor of chicago
former political operative for the
clintons for obama white house chief of
staff
you know a real machine politician type
guy rahm emanuel took to the sunday
shows this weekend
to lament the fact that the gop
is no longer a conservative party i'm
sure he was so so sad about
this jane has uh uh said the word you
know conservative or
agenda first of all this is not a
conservative party you want to look at a
conservative
pick up john boehner's book pick up
former president bush's book
that's conservative this is a
reactionary party built
on both resentment and race that is what
the party's going
pause i
do not want to hear about the politics
of resentment
and race from the party of black lives
matter
i don't want to hear any accusations
that the gop is now focused on race and
resentment
from democrats who actively encouraged
race rioters last year that burned down
the country
and are still doing they're still
encouraging this sort of thing
so that like so much of what rahm
emanuel says
completely disingenuous it's what the
left often does he is projecting unto
his opponents that which he does himself
okay fair enough but then
listen to his point about what true
conservatism is when you think of true
conservatism
what names pop to mind
i wh what do i know maybe edmund burke
uh maybe john adams maybe
maybe ronald reagan so it's a little
complicated but maybe ronald reagan
maybe gosh i don't know a lot of people
who are very conservative in american
history
does john boehner come to mind does
george w
bush come to mind these guys are
famously
not that conservative john boehner would
call the more conservative members of
his party lunatics
wackos he called ted cruz the lucifer
himself
something like that george w bush comes
from the most famous liberal republican
family
in the country even more famous than the
romneys
when bush ran for president he
positioned himself as a
compassionate conservative as if to say
regular conservatives are not
compassionate regular conservatives are
cruel and heartless and inhumane but i'm
a compassionate conservative
just like his father who was part of the
liberal wing of the republican party
that's why he was part of reagan's
ticket
reagan was the conservative bush was the
liberal they come together and unify the
party
when bush became president he said we're
going to create a kindler gentler nation
right when nancy reagan said
kindler and gentler than whom you're
calling us unkind and
ungentle but you hear this first of all
people like rahm emanuel were
viciously attacking boehner and bush
while they were in office because
they'll attack any republican
but now they're saying these are the
good republicans and this is why
you got to tune out what john boehner is
saying right now this is why you got to
tune out what george bush is saying
right now
because these are the liberals favorite
conservatives
what what someone like rahm emanuel is
saying here is they're they're
they're doing the conservatism in the
right way which is to put up a little
bit of a fight
but ultimately to to fail so that we can
not only succeed as leftists but the
fake conservatives will
legitimize our regime right they're the
court jester conservatives
they they come into the kingdom of
liberalism they do their little dance
but they don't really threaten the way
that the rule is is
carried out here emmanuel goes on the
other piece of this is
you talk about an agenda there's in 2020
there was no platform
there's no agenda it's about donald
trump you know parties exist for two
reasons
set out to set policy principles they
didn't have that in 2020 they still
don't have that
number two to win elections it took 90
years to find a president that could
both lose the white house the house and
the senate
and donald trump did that this is about
donald trump
and his grievances and the other piece
of this that makes no sense to me
you're you have an election there are
three things that both parties have
the republicans have redistricting they
have
uh basically restricting voter access
and they are going to also have
the ability in this area to cut off uh
any part of his in history they have
i don't even know what he's what point
is he trying to make at the end they're
going to try to
the republicans are cutting off their
history
they want to deny their history this
from the party of the kkk
from the democratic party how are
republicans denying their history if
anything
republicans are returning to their
history the embrace of
protection in trade the embrace of
tariffs to some small degree
is not a an abdication of con of the
conservative agenda or the republican
agenda that's a return to it the
republican party was founded on tariffs
abraham lincoln the first republican
president said show me a tariff i'll
show you the greatest nation on earth
so even even on his point of the agenda
he's just completely wrong
the republicans did have a real agenda
in 2016 and 2020. it was the first time
they've articulated a serious agenda
in my lifetime it was just not an agenda
that the left approved of
for most of my lifetime i'm thinking
mccain i'm thinking romney i'm thinking
bush
the republican agenda was basically
indistinguishable from the democrat
agenda
on things like immigration on things
like
trade on things like the welfare state i
mean you kind of the republicans want to
shrink it a little
but they didn't end up shrinking it bush
actually grew it right mccain actually
preserved it romney actually grew and he
was governor of massachusetts
they basically all agreed on everything
then trump comes along
and he says yeah we need to reduce
immigration immigration is a big problem
we need to actually reduce it yeah on
trade we're getting ripped off we have
to be more skeptical of these
international free trade regimes he
offered
an alternative vision and what the
democrats said
they're trying to pretend that that's
not a different vision but what the
democrats are really saying here is hold
on wait a second
that actually threatens us the
trump and trump supporters views on
immigration on trade on manufacturing
on national identity that actually
threatens
what we want to do so we need to
complete completely delegitimize that
we need to change various election rules
before the 2020 election
i won't even respond directly to what
rahm emanuel said on that point
because i don't think youtube will let
me but we they're saying we need to
fundamentally overhaul elections now
from in hr1 and s1
these the corrupt politicians act being
considered by congress
which would federalize the elections
they seem really scared they don't seem
very confident do they
not because there's no republican agenda
but because for the first time in
decades
there was a substantive republican
agenda so many people don't know about
this stuff they don't they they just
weren't educated into it when they were
very
very young well one way that we can fix
that for the next generation
is tuttle twins how do you explain
economics to a seven-year-old
should your pre-teen care about the
government schools today are not
teaching the principles of freedom
history is watered down key principles
omitted altogether and time and
attention
are given to things of lesser importance
woke socialist ideas are creeping into
our classrooms and curricula across the
country
so our friends over at tuttle twins are
doing something about it
they have created the tuttle twins show
an animated show that teaches kids
principles of freedom like free market
economics limited government and free
speech
title twins just opened an investment
round to the public at
www.tuttletwins.tv
where anyone can invest in the show and
help bring it to life people are loving
it the title twin show is now
the world's number one crowdfunded kids
show and the investment round is filling
up fast if you want to help bring the
tuttle twins show to life
go to tuttletwins.tv to learn more about
the investment opportunity
today what is that url say it with me
that is www.tuttletwins
and help bring this show to life if you
own an apple device
i've got great news for you all of the
daily wires latest news commentary and
analysis
is now available on apple news we cover
everything that you are not getting
anywhere else so if you want to make
your news feed
infinitely better just head on over to
apple news on your device
search for the daily wire and hit the
follow button
every day on my show i talk about a lot
of fabulous products and services
from sponsors that i love and use but we
want to get to know you better so that
we can choose our sponsors with you in
mind so please head on over to
dailywire.com knowles fill out my
audience survey to tell us a little more
about yourself
to sweeten the whole experience those of
you that complete the survey will be
entered to win a one thousand dollar
gift card but you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show so if
you want to increase your chances of
winning one
thousand smackaroos head on over to ben
to drew to matt get access to their
surveys as well my survey link
most important one daily wire dot com
slash knowles k wlas we'll be right back
with a lot more
democrat rahm emanuel says the gop it's
just not conservative anymore that's
what he says on the sunday shows
and he's a democrat so you should
believe him and he says
that we should all listen all we
republicans should listen to bush
and listen to uh boehner right that's
that would be good because
because rahm emanuel famous democrat
operative he has our best interests at
heart it reminds me of this thing both
parties do it but it's so
it's so saccharine and obviously
disingenuous
i i would say probably most republicans
have said this at various times i've
probably said it too well they'll say
hey
look i think there should be a healthy
democrat party
it's just not this one look it uh i look
i know i'm a republican but
we need a healthy two-party system we
need a healthy democratic party and
that's why
the democrats need to accept all of my
advice
to ha for how to make their party
stronger because look i really have
their best interests at heart
i just think we need a healthy two-part
it's like no you don't you think that
the democrats should be abolished
you think they're a horrible party who
have a horrible
horrible vision for our country and it
would be better if none of them showed
up to vote
or ran for office or whatever and
republicans ran everything of course
that's what you think
and vice versa when the democrat look
guys
i know i'm a democrat but i just think
republicans you should really listen to
john boehner that would be great for you
uh
i'm not so sure rahm you're not really
convincing me
so so saccharine and ridiculous so it's
bad enough when it comes from democrats
but then what what the democrats are
really saying is
listen to our guys listen to
the republicans who accomplish nothing
other than legitimize
the democratic rule guys like
representative adam kinzinger who is a
republican at least nominally
who spends most of his time going on
liberal news outlets
and attacking the gop and specifically
attacking the conservatives within the
gop so adam kinzinger goes on
cbs sunday show and he says the gop
it's a sinking ship it's incredible so
liz cheney uh is saying exactly what
kevin mccarthy said
the day of the insurrection she's just
consistently been saying it
and a few weeks later kevin mccarthy
changed to
attacking other people and so i think
what the reality is
is as a party we have to have an
internal look
and a full accounting as to what led to
january 6. i mean right now it's
basically
the titanic we're like you know in this
in the middle of this slow sink we have
a band playing on the deck
telling everybody it's fine and
meanwhile as i've said you know donald
trump's running around trying to find
women's clothing to get on the first
lifeboat
and i think there's a few of us that are
just saying guys this is not good not
just for the future of the party
but this is not good for the future of
this country we're four months after
january 6 an insurrection something that
was
unthinkable in this country and the
message from the people that want to get
rid of liz cheney
is to say it's just time to focus on the
future and move on
like this was 10 years ago and we've
been obsessed about it since
jen where to begin with this this
ridiculous person
january 6 was an insurrection something
unthinkable in this country
i don't think it was unthinkable and you
know why i don't think an insurrection
was unthinkable in this country
because the left had been pursuing one
for eight months
before no well they on january 6
the trump or insurrectionists attacked a
government building oh government
you mean like the multiple government
buildings that blm burned to the ground
during 2020. well and they think it's
worth threatening
civilians were them i guess they were
threatening
members of the house that's the claim at
least going after
going after citizens uh you mean like
the many many citizens from coast to
coast that blm threatened burned down
their homes burned down
their businesses and killed in 2020 like
that
unthinkable well what happened
because with blm dozens of people were
killed and
countless cities were burned to the
ground on january 6th
some guy in a horn helmet danced around
on the house floor
so what i'm not excusing that i think
it's
bad to dance around government buildings
in a horn helmet
i'm really i'm not i don't think it's
good i think frankly i think they should
be punished for it
but they're not comparable not only is
january 6 not the worst
insurrection worst most terrible thing
worse than pearl harbor worse than 911
it's not it's not just that it's
it's that you can't you can't even
compare it to the blm stuff you can't
even compare it to what antifa does
regularly
the what the left has done is so much
worse but adam kinzinger doesn't want to
talk about that
because adam kinzinger exists his whole
raison d'etre as a
as a conservative as a republican
is to attack the gop and defend the left
he's one of the guys who voted for the
impeachment
the one area that i agree with him here
is i do think we should have an
investigation
into what happened on january 6th
because what we were told
in the days right after january 6
is that republican trump supporters they
planted bombs they planted bombs
outside the capitol and at the party
headquarters and they killed people
and they threw fire extinguishers at
cops and killed cops
and they they were violent and they were
they were not only trying to kill people
but actually succeeded in killing people
and then what did we learn
what did we learn
the officer who sadly died died of an
unrelated stroke
days later we learned that the only
person
actually killed in the political
violence of that day was
a trump supporter killed by capitol
police
you hear so much about police brutality
when it fits the left-wing narrative you
don't hear about it when it when it
doesn't fit their narrative when it
contradicts their narrative and what
about those bombs
no we remember there were bombs planted
outside the capitol
by by trump supporters appeared and yet
we've never heard anything about it
we don't know who planted them that's it
just we don't know
so yeah i think there should be an
investigation because the more the more
that there has been an investigation
it has disproved the leftist narrative
on it
and it has defended
the the conservative line adam kinzinger
but he's defending liz cheney we talked
about liz cheney last week i won't get
into her too much more
but the liz cheney battle is kind of a
battle for the soul of the republican
party that's why it matters
no one no one really cares about the
leader of the gop house conference per
se
the reason that this battle matters is
because it's a fight between the
squishes and the conservatives for the
future of the party
and it's gotten complicated because
while liz cheney represents the
neo-conservative wing of the party
that basically the liberal imperialist
wing of the party
the person that the conservatives put up
is this woman elise stefanik who's
actually more liberal than liz janey
so that makes it a little bit difficult
but kinzinger is going out and defending
cheney because what cheney and kinzinger
have been spending their last
years doing is just going on these
left-wing shows and talking to left-wing
outlets
and writing for left-wing outlets and
defending the libs against the
conservatives
so jim clyburn a democrat
has now come out and said that getting
the republicans getting rid of liz
cheney
is quote cancel culture
that's exactly what it's about and you
know uh i know
green lives are much politically but you
know
that's how we grow as a country this
whole thing that everybody
it ought to be marching in lockstep that
is what leads people to destruction
people are to have a diversity
of thought diversity is very very
important
we want to limit it to gender and
sometimes through race
it is also about thought and i want to
see a strong republican party
my parents were republicans and i would
love to see this party honor them
but this party republican party today is
showing so much
dishonor to the people who made it
possible
the people who down from abraham lincoln
kept this party alive
on the basis of anti-slavery uh which
itself
was a big lie and now they're
perpetuating it
now they talk a lot about cancer culture
this is the classic cancer culture
they are perpetrating that which they
argue that they are against wow guys
i'm even better than i thought i was i i
hate to brag on the show here
but i did not realize when i when i
threw the clyburn club in here
i did not realize that he was going to
be proving my point
about how disingenuous it is when people
from other parties talk about how they
want your party to be really strong
he just did he just did my riff he just
now listen
i'm not a i don't agree with liz cheney
okay
i don't you i think you actually do
agree with liz cheney on a lot of things
but that's beside the point
i don't agree with liz cheney but i'm
just saying i support
a strong republican party no you don't
you want to see the republican party
washed away to the sea never to be heard
from again
and you're pretending that you want a
strong republican party so that you can
sound reasonable and moderate but you
don't you're a partisan democrat who
fights
tooth and nail against the republicans
every single chance you get
he then contradicts him he even did the
thing of and they are bringing shame
to people like abraham lincoln
the way you know he actually gave a
little bit of a tell in how disingenuous
his argument is here because
they're bringing great shame to people
like abraham lincoln father
follow the logic abraham lincoln who
founded the republican party on
anti-slavery which itself was a lie
wait hold on wait where am i
because you just said the reason that
these current republicans are bad
is because they're breaking with
the great history of the republican
party
which was founded on anti-slavery but oh
wait a second i just said the republican
party was founded on anti-slavery
but that was a lie
oh okay so if it was a so then the then
the new republicans aren't that bad
because they're not betraying the old
party because the party was always
terrible
well no i'm just and he ties himself
into knots
my big argument against liz cheney is
that people like jim clyburn really like
her or at least are pretending to like
her right now
because they know that she in a position
of leadership weakens the republican
party
now the problem for us right now is that
the alternative is possibly worse at
least stephanie can't we just put up a
conservative
can we put can't we at least here are
the two things i want
vaguely conservative at least and
doesn't spend all of his time attacking
his own party
that's those are the two things i want
for someone who is in republican
leadership
so liz cheney actually she's sort of you
know moderately conservative
she's not a total lib moderately
conservative but she spends all her time
attacking the party okay well she's got
to go then
and elise stefanik does not spend her
time attacking the party but she's
significantly more liberal than liz
cheney so can we can you just get like a
conservative up there
like and any conservative who doesn't
hate his own party i guess that's too
much to ask
this is cancel culture i guess to jim's
main point here he's saying this is
cancel culture it's not
cancel culture to hold people
accountable
and to show people consequences for the
things they say when the left
uses those kinds of words and says you
know cancel culture is really about
accountability it's really about
consequences
i agree with them and as far as it goes
yes people should be held accountable
for things they do people should face
consequences one of the big problems in
our culture today is people don't really
face consequences
or rather only conservatives face
consequences
getting back to kenzinger's stupid point
about the worst most terrible
insurrection in history
a guy who says he i guess he's sort of
conservative
dances around with horns and all of
those people are going to go to prison
for a long time
blm burns down the country very few of
them face consequences
that's the problem cancel culture is a
specific phenomenon
it is when ordinary people
are ostracized and face professional and
personal reprisals
for saying perfectly ordinary and good
things
for waving the american flag for saying
i support
cops over criminals and they get cancer
that's cancer culture
i am it does not therefore follow that
no one should ever be held accountable
for anything
when the left says well you you
conservatives had cancer culture in the
50s when you put communists in jail
yes we did and it was awesome it was
great bring it back
baby when you've got people working
to completely undermine our country and
upend our way of life
as the card-carrying communists were in
the 1950s they were working on behalf of
a foreign government
our enemy in the cold war it is totally
right to punish them for that
that's great bill buckley had a great
line about this he's saying
i'll try to do it in my perfect buckley
goes you know i'm not saying that
communists ought to be thrown in prison
but i'm not saying that they have any
right not to be thrown in prison
either totally right i absolutely agree
with that
yes because communists waving the fl the
hammer and sickle
are different than americans waving the
star-spangled banner
the substance matters too this this
question of symbolism is is really
important we're getting so dumb
there was a judge in maryland a maryland
district court judge on wednesday
banned court employees from wearing
apparel that have
thin blue line designs because the you
know the thin blue line
is it's the american flag with the blue
through it and it says yeah i support
the cops over the criminals
and you know the more we see videos of
people in canada you know cops in canada
arresting pastors
i think the less likely we're going to
be to just reflexively support the blue
but here in america yes we support the
cops over the criminals the left
supports the criminals over the cops the
right supports the cops over the
criminals the reason i don't like the
thin blue line symbol too much
is it's actually a violation of flag
code it's a transformation of the
american flag
in a way that i think is actually
somewhat disrespectful but i support the
idea
the judge says no no thin blue line
stuff no
we support the cops back the blue stuff
now
i don't know do you think that if an
employee at the court
wore a button that said black lives
matter do you think that would be
prohibited i don't know maybe it would
but we we know that in other places
there have been plenty of news stories
about other corporations about other
organizations
where you can wear the blm stuff but you
can't wear the back the blue stuff
where you can wear the blm or even
antifa or even che guevara's face on a
t-shirt
but you can't wear a maga hat only
some of the symbols are being banned
because those symbols are reflect
reflections on our standards and our
standards are changing and conservatives
don't have any language
with which to describe this they don't
have it yet because we've been left
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it's the title of my book which is
available now
for pre-order so if you want a way out
of this i strongly recommend taking a
look
at the book give you a great example
on on the substance of these politics
right
so democrats have earmarked millions of
dollars
in this upcoming spending bill for all
of their pet projects
millions and millions of dollars here's
just a list of some of them
million bucks for a cultural
place-making initiative
designed to celebrate the history and
culture of black los angeles
by representative karen bass of
california an
actual communist a woman who actually
worked for communist organizations
for a very long time and visited
communist places and defended them
i'm not i'm not being hyperbolic at all
when you call karen bass a communist
the project is described as an
innovative 1.3 mile public private
streetscape improvement to celebrate
black culture
it's so it's so cliche at this point
that i won't
i don't i will say imagine if you had
a million dollar project to celebrate
white culture imagine what would that do
you'd be oh my gosh the international
headlines
the riots that that would provoke but
what about the hispanics they don't get
a million bucks to celebrate their
culture what about the asians they don't
get to celebrate their culture what
about the italians the most persecuted
minority ever in the history of america
what about that
no no no okay million dollars for to
celebrate black culture
in wisconsin democrat rep mark pokken is
asking for a million bucks for a 55
000 square foot space for black
enterprise art history performance and
culture okay so another
specifically racialist black
artistic thing illinois rep
sherry bustos asking for three quarters
of a million dollars to create a youth
equity center
to help children address the necessary
social determinants of health to be
successful i don't even know what that
means i assume this is just a complete
slush fund
rep hakeem jeffries who's uh who's i
believe it's his uncle
uh professor uh jeffries who i talk
about in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
uh jeffrey's had this great that was a
little bit late on the ding but that's
okay that's all right i still remember
it's an important one
uh jeffrey's had this idea that there
are sun people and ice people
and that the black people are the sun
people and they're good and they have
melanin
and the whites are savages they're ice
people nick cannon the actor
carried this ridiculous ideology into
the 21st century recently
and sort of got a slap on the wrist for
it so jeffries is his
uh nephew his relative he's requesting
three-quarters of a million bucks
for a program for quote inclusion and
health
healthy discussions around difficult
issues such as racism gender
discrimination cultural bias so again
just a slush fund for nonsense
donald payne jr earmarks over a million
dollars for
the center for child and human
development for blah blah blah
meaningless jargon rep barbara lee
asking for a million bucks
to provide culturally relevant medical
services to the black community what
does that mean culturally relevant i
don't know sounds a little
suspect to me same thing another million
bucks another half million bucks another
half a million bucks another quarter
million bucks
the list goes on what's the republican
response to this the republican response
to these
slush fund projects is
wow look at all this crazy wasteful
spending
wow if you elect us we won't spend any
of that money for
for our priorities wow we'll and
actually they probably will they'll just
they'll just give lip service to
opposing them
wow look how kooky this is that's all
the republican responses
the republican response should be elect
us
and you see all that money that the
democrats are going to spend on their
nonsense
we're going to take all of that money
and we're going to spend it on good
things
but what about the debt and deficit yeah
we have to deal with that i agree but
politics is downstream of culture
to quote andrew breitbart and to quote a
lot of the people who
would oppose this sort of a plan we need
to take the money
that is going to be spent there's no
you're not going to reduce
the spending it's just not going to
happen not in our current culture
if ronald reagan couldn't do it you
can't do it either
take the money that is already going to
be spent because
money is power right money is political
power
take that and put it into good things
put it into the 1776 commission
put it into the 1620 center for american
history celebrating the pilgrims
put it into the george washington center
for justice and liberty
and true equality under the law wow
wouldn't that be great
we need to flex political power
which means spending money because
that's where the political power is
expressed
on good things i'm not saying you oppose
the
the black cultural center with a at a
white cultural center that's not what
i'm saying i'm saying you oppose the
black cultural center
with the george washington mural for
how great america and christianity
and our traditional culture is do that
that will help that will actually
change the culture and then you're
you're doing it through politics because
politics and culture can't be
totally neatly separated of course
that that is a way forward unfortunately
our guys basically share the same world
views
as the left that's just how it works
caitlyn i got to get to caitlyn jenner
caitlyn jenner just came out for a path
to citizenship
california's labor force includes 1.75
million undocumented immigrants
should they have a path to citizenship
i would hope so
i am for legal immigration okay
what's been happening on the border was
honestly one of the reasons i decided
to run for governor
i was watching people dying come across
the river
kids in cages whatever you want to call
them they should
have a chance at citizenship absolutely
yeah yeah they should
why why are republicans going to vote
for this guy
not only is he supporting amnesty for
illegal aliens
the issue right there are many issues
that you call the issue
this is a very very important one
would give democrats a huge electoral
advantage maybe a lock
it's such a such an injustice it's such
a violation of the law
it so encourages more illegal
immigration and not only that
but he's parroting the left's talking
point on kids in cages
the the left-wing argument trump threw
the kids in the cages
it's so unjust to detain illegally he's
using the same point
so why would anyone support him
well because you know that would so own
the libs if we showed the democrats that
they're the real transphobes or whatever
oh if we adopted all of their views
caitlyn jenner already already has
adopted the left swing the left's view
on very important issues so what would
be the point
in electing him we need to offer an
alternative folks but are we going to be
able to do that or is our politics just
ossified
into the democrats and then the
sort of fake republicans who sort of
just exist to prop up the democrats and
really it's all governed by dr fauci who
will let you get back to normal maybe
next year but probably not
even then i'm michael nolis the michael
knoll show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show